Kensington in wealthy West London the
constituency with the highest average
salary in the UK and some of the most
deprived wards in the country once a
true-blue conservative stronghold this
is now one of the most marginal
constituencies after labour took the
seat at the last election by just 20
votes and now there's a new challenger
in the form of the Liberal Democrats who
hope to take votes from the 68% of
constituents who voted to remain in the
EU the Lib Dems can literally go
everywhere in what is a constituency of
two halves so we are pulling soft
Romania's but also soft labour
candidates who are all drifting to the
Liberal Democrats - what - stop brexit
and stop Jeremy Corbett this is a
constituency that voted heavily to
remain are you not worried that you're
going to be disciplining the remain boat
here and letting in an alternative
cancer I think the Liberal Democrats
because we can pull from both the
Conservatives and the Labour side are
very well positioned to win in this
constituency without splitting the
remain vote the remain vote does not
belong to any one political party this
is a community still scarred by the
Grenville tower fire a painful reminder
that there are other issues than brexit
at play I think people are looking for
answers as to how they're going to make
sure that this doesn't happen again
for me that's what justice is about
really is about making sure that it
doesn't happen again so how you gonna
manifest properly in public housing how
you're gonna regulate properly how
you're gonna invest in the fire service
how are you gonna basically make sure
that you're protecting the lives of
people who live in public housing
Labour's Emma Dent code who won the seat
last time is keen to talk about her
party's domestic agenda a lot of people
will vote for me because they know me
I've been around a long time I've lived
here most of my life
I have my secrets and so a lot of a lot
of One Nation Tories one with a better
expression voted for me last time and
will again and a lot of people elsewhere
who never thought I had a chance last
time and will vote for me again I'm so
confident then I'm quietly confident we
still have a lot of work to do and what
are your main messages then as you're
fighting this constituency everybody
wants
to live somewhere safe and secure and
warm and everybody wants their children
and grandchildren to be able to live
somewhere safe and secure preferably
near them if that's possible
people want access to health care when
they need it they want GPS to have time
to see them when they need to see them
education and so on
everybody wants pretty much the same and
in this heavily remained seat the
Conservative candidate wants to talk
about domestic policy - we're offering a
very positive one nation domestic agenda
we're going to invest thirty three point
nine billion pounds more into our NHS
we're investing 14 billion pounds into
schools and were putting 1369 more
officers into the Met Police we've got
an agreed deal with Europe I think that
we need to get on and implement that so
how did you very well I was very much so
like the country I was pretty undecided
to be honest I was 52 48 but in the end
I did vote for brexit I voted to leave
and do you think that's a problem on the
doorstep here no I don't think it's a
problem because people are very much so
aware that the referendum did happen
three years ago but what do the voters
think what are the kind of big issues
for you as I was listening on the news
this morning and anything anyone else to
gain traction any other issue really and
so brexit all the way from me so I'm
married to a Dutch girl and so whilst
they have passports and they can get out
I don't I can't quite so much so yeah
it's it's massively important I think
it's going to be massively important for
every single aspect of this community I
think it's gotta be Tory it's got to be
because I think the Lib Dems will hold
things up again
certainly not labour so I think we just
have to go there because you want to get
it done get it done let's eat yeah it
needs to be done now you know we've had
over three years at this elections
coming up yeah are you excited about the
prospect of voting for someone I am in a
way actually to be honest just I think
I'm definitely vote for someone
different this time
normally a conservative voter but I just
I just don't feel like they're right for
me in this election so here you can
debate for this time I'm thinking Lib
Dems this time so who you think you're
facing for at the election labour yeah
laborers oh my is that what I said
before earlier as well that they're
going to we are hoping they are going to
bring a better change which is good for
not for only for us for everyone for
everyone else yeah well we'll see what
happens hopefully it's lay upon us yeah
you never know we've been hammered with
so much useless information that people
have got to the point where they're just
like you know what I don't even want to
I don't I don't want to think about this
anymore
people not have enough money to eat you
I mean to commute to do anything they
don't have enough money to do anything
after spending the day in Kensington I
have to say I'm finding this
constituency in particular quite hard to
predict will the Lib Dems end up taking
more votes off labor or the
Conservatives or could they even win in
this heavily remain seat it's gone from
being a safe conservative constituency
to a to a marginal and now it's a
three-way fight Kensington has sadly
been on a journey in one of the most
volatile elections and living memory
there are few seats more unpredictable
than Kensington Sophie Ridge Sky News
you